the following is a conversation with
Christos Kudrow vice president of
engineering at Google and head of search
and discovery at YouTube also known as
the YouTube algorithm YouTube has
approximately 1.9 billion users and
every day people watch over 1 billion
hours of YouTube video it is the second
most popular search engine behind Google
itself for many people it is not only a
source of entertainment but also how we
learn new ideas from math and physics
videos to podcasts to debates opinions
ideas from out-of-the-box thinkers and
activists some of the most tense
challenging and impactful topics in the
world today YouTube and other content
platforms receive criticism from both
viewers and creators as they should
because the engineering task before them
is hard and they don't always succeed
and the impact of their work is truly
world-changing to me YouTube has been an
incredible wellspring of knowledge I've
watched hundreds if not thousands of
lectures that changed the way I see many
fun about those ideas in math science
engineering and philosophy but it does
put a mirror to ourselves and keeps the
responsibility of the steps we take in
each of our online educational journeys
into the hands of each of us the YouTube
algorithm has an important role in that
journey of helping us find new exciting
ideas to learn about that's a difficult
and an exciting problem for an
artificial intelligence system as I've
said in lectures and other forums
recommendation systems will be one of
the most impactful areas of AI in the
21st century
and YouTube is one of the biggest
recommendation systems in the world this
is the artificial intelligence podcast
if you enjoy it subscribe on YouTube
give it five stars an Apple podcast
follow on Spotify supported on patreon
or simply connect with me on Twitter
Alex Friedman spelled Fri D ma a.m. I
recently started doing ads at the end of
the introduction I'll do one or two
minutes after introducing the episode
and never any ads in the middle that can
break the flow of the conversation
I hope that works for you and doesn't
hurt the listening experience this show
is presented by cash app the number one
finance app in the App Store I
personally use cash app to send money to
friends but you can also use it to buy
sell and deposit Bitcoin in just seconds
cash app also has a new investing
feature you can buy fractions of a stock
say $1 worth no matter what the stock
price is brokerage services are provided
by cash app investing a subsidiary of
square and member si PC I'm excited to
be working with cash app to support one
of my favorite organizations called
first best known for their first
robotics and Lego competitions they
educate and inspire hundreds of
thousands of students in over 110
countries and have a perfect rating and
Charity Navigator
which means that donated money is used
to maximum effectiveness when you get
cash app from the App Store Google Play
and use code Lex podcast you'll get ten
dollars in cash app will also donate ten
dollars to the first which again is an
organization that I've personally seen
inspire girls and boys the dream of
engineering a better world and now
here's my conversation with Christos
Gaudreau YouTube is the world's second
most popular search engine behind Google
of course we watch more than 1 billion
hours of YouTube videos a day more than
Netflix and facebook video combined
YouTube creators upload over 500
thousand hours of video every day
average lifespan of a human being just
for comparison is about 700,000 hours so
what's uploaded every single day is just
enough for a human to watch in a
lifetime so let me ask an absurd
philosophical question if from birth
when I was born and there's many people
born today with the internet I watched
YouTube videos non-stop do you think
there are trajectories through YouTube
video space that can maximize my average
happiness or maybe education or my
growth as a human being I think there
are some great trajectories through
YouTube videos but I wouldn't recommend
that anyone
and all of their waking hours or all of
their hours watching YouTube I mean I
think about the fact that YouTube has
been really great for my kids for
instance my oldest daughter you know
she's been watching YouTube for several
years she watches Tyler Oakley and the
vlogbrothers and I know that it's had a
very profound and positive impact on her
character and my younger daughter she's
a ballerina and her teachers tell her
that YouTube is a huge advantage for her
because she can practice a routine and
watch like professional dancers do that
same routine and stop it and back it up
and rewind and all that stuff right so
it's been really good for them and then
even my son is a sophomore in college he
he got through his linear algebra class
because of a channel called three blue
one brown which you know helps you
understand linear algebra but in a way
that would be very hard for anyone to do
on a whiteboard or a chalkboard and so I
think that those experiences from my
point of view were very good and and so
I can imagine really good trajectories
through YouTube yes have you looked at
do you think of broadly about that
trajectory over a period cuz YouTube was
growing up now so over a period of years
you just kind of gave a few anecdotal
examples but you know I used to watch
certain shows on YouTube I don't anymore
I've moved on to other shows and
ultimately you want people to from
YouTube's perspective to stay on YouTube
to grow as human beings on YouTube so
you have to think not just what makes
them engage today or this month but also
over a period of years absolutely that's
right I mean if YouTube is going to
continue to enrich people's lives then
you know then it has to grow with them
and and people's interests change over
time and so I think we've we've been
working on this problem and I'll just
say it broadly is like how to introduce
diversity and introduce people who are
watching one thing to something else
they might like
we've been working on that problem all
the eight years I've been at YouTube
it's a hard problem because I mean of
course it's trivial to introduce
diversity that doesn't help a random
video I could just randomly select a
video from the billions that we have
it's likely not to even be in your
language so haha the likelihood that you
would watch it and develop a new
interest is very very low and so what
you want to do when you're trying to
increase diversity is find something
that is not too similar to the things
that you've watched but also something
that you might be likely to watch and
that balance finding that spot between
those two things is quite challenging so
the diversity of content diversity of
ideas it's uh it's a really difficult
it's the thing like that's almost
impossible to define alright like what's
different so how do you think about that
so two examples is a I'm a huge fan of
three blue one Brown say and then one
diversity I wasn't even aware of a
channel called veritasium width which is
a great science physics whatever channel
so one version of diversity is showing
me Derek's veritasium channel which I
was really excited to discover actually
now watch a lot of his videos okay so
you're a person who's watching some math
channels and you might be interested in
some other science or math channels so
like you mentioned the first kind of
diversity is just show you some some
things from other channels that are
related but not just you know not all
the three blue one Brown Channel throw
in a couple others so so that's the
maybe the first kind of diversity that
we started with many many years ago
taking a bigger leap is is about I mean
the mechanisms we do we use for that is
is we basically cluster videos and
channels together mostly videos we do
every almost everything at the video
level and so we'll we'll make some kind
of a cluster
some embedding process and then and then
measure you know what is the likelihood
that a that users who watch one cluster
might also watch another cluster that's
very distinct so we may come to find
that that people who watch science
videos also like jazz this is possible
right and so and so because of that
relationship that we've identified
through the through the embeddings and
then the measurement of the people who
watch both we might recommend a jazz
video once in a while so there's this
clustering the embedding space of jazz
videos and science videos and so you
kind of try to look at aggregate
statistics where if a lot of people that
jump from science cluster to the jazz
cluster tend to remain as engaged or
become more engaged then that's that
means those two are they should hop back
and forth and they'll be happy right
there's a higher likelihood that a
person from who's watching science would
like jazz then the person watching
science would like I don't know backyard
railroads or something else right and so
we can try to measure these likelihoods
and use that to make the best
recommendation we can so okay so we'll
talk about the machine learning of that
but I have to linger on things that
neither you or anyone have an answer to
there's gray areas of truth which is for
example now I can't believe I'm going
there but politics it it happens so that
the certain people believe certain
things and they're very certain about
them let's move outside the red versus
blue
politics of today's world but there's
different ideologies for example in
college I read quite a lot of iron rand
i studied and that's a particular
philosophical ideologies I find I found
it interesting to explore okay so that
was that kind of space I've kind of
moved on from that cluster
intellectually but it nevertheless is an
interesting cluster there's I was born
in Soviet Union socialism communism is a
certain kind of political idea
that's really interesting to explore
again objectively just there's a set of
beliefs about how the economy should
work and so on and so it's hard to know
what's true or not in terms of people
within those communities they're often
advocating that this is how we achieve
utopia in this world and they're pretty
certain about it so how do you try to
manage politics in this chaotic divisive
world not positively any kind of ideas
in terms of filtering what people should
watch next and in terms of also not
letting certain things be on YouTube
this is exceptionally difficult
responsibility right well the
responsibility to get this right is our
top priority and and the first comes
down to making sure that we have good
clear rules of the road right like just
because we have freedom of speech
doesn't mean that you can literally say
anything right like we as a society have
accepted certain restrictions on our
freedom of speech there are things like
libel laws and things like that and so
where we can draw a clear line we do and
we continue to evolve that line over
time however as you point it out
wherever you draw the line there's going
to be a border line and in that border
line area we are going to maybe not
remove videos but we will try to reduce
the recommendations of them or the
proliferation of them by demoting them
and then alternatively in those
situations try to raise what we would
call Thorat ativ or credible sources of
information so we're not trying to I
mean you mentioned Iran and communism
you know those are those are two like
valid points of view that people are
going to debate and discuss and and of
course people who believe and one of the
other of those things are going to try
to persuade other people to their point
of view and so we're not trying to
settle that
choose a side or anything like that what
we're trying to do is make sure that the
the people who are expressing those
point of view and and offering those
positions are authoritative and credible
so let me ask a question
about people I don't like personally you
heard me I don't care if you leave
comments on this is uh and but sometimes
there's brilliantly funny which is
trolls so it's people who kind of mock I
mean the Internet is full the reddit of
mock style comedy where people just kind
of make fun of point out that the
emperor has no clothes and there's
brilliant comedy and that but sometimes
it can get cruel and mean so on that on
the mean point and sorry to linger on
these things that have no good answers
but it actually is I totally hear you
that this is really important you're
trying to solve it but how do you reduce
the meanness of people on YouTube I
understand that anyone who uploads
YouTube videos has to become resilient
to a certain amount of meanness like
I've heard that from many creators and
we would we are trying in various ways
comment ranking allowing certain
features to block people to reduce or or
make that that meanness or that trolling
behavior less effective on YouTube yeah
and so I mean it's it's very important
but it's something that we're we're
gonna keep having to work on and and you
know as we improve it maybe we'll get to
a point where where people don't have to
suffer this sort of meanness when they
upload YouTube videos I hope we do but
you know but it just does seem to be
something that you have to be able to
deal with as a YouTube creator now it is
do you have a hope that he mentioned two
things that can I agree was so there's a
machine-learning approach of ranking
comments based on whatever based on how
much they contribute to the healthy
conversation let's put it that way then
the other is almost an interface
question of how do you how does the
Creator filter so block or how does how
do humans themselves the users of
YouTube manage their own conversation do
you have hope that these two tools will
create a better society without limiting
freedom of speech too much without sort
of Antonin even like saying that people
what do you mean limiting sort of
curating speech I mean I think that that
overall is our whole project here at
YouTube right like yeah we fundamentally
believe and I personally believe very
much that YouTube can be great it's been
great for my kids I think it can be
great for society but it's absolutely
critical that we get this responsibility
part right and that's why it's our top
priority Susan Wojcicki who's the CEO of
YouTube she says something that I
personally find very inspiring which is
that we want to do our jobs today in a
manner so that people 20 and 30 years
from now will look back and say you know
YouTube they they really figured this
out they really found a way to strike
the right balance between the openness
and the value that the openness has and
also making sure that we are meeting our
responsibilities to users in society so
the burden on YouTube actually is quite
incredible and the one thing that people
don't I don't give enough credit to the
seriousness and the magnitude of the
problem I think so I I personally hope
that you do solve it because a lot is in
your hand a lot is riding on your
success or failure so it's besides of
course running a successful company
you're also curating the content of the
internet and the conversation the
internet that's a powerful thing so one
thing that people wander about is how
much of it
can be solved with pure machine learning
so looking at the data studying the data
and creating algorithms that curate the
comments curate the content and how much
of it needs human intervention meaning
people here YouTube in a room sitting
and thinking about what is the nature of
truth what is what are the ideals that
we should be promoting that kind of
thing so algorithm versus human input
what's your sense I mean my own
experience has demonstrated that you
need both of those things algorithms I
mean you're familiar with machine
learning algorithm and the thing they
need most is data and the data is
generated by humans and so for instance
when we're building a system to try to
figure out which are the videos that are
misinformation or borderline policy
violations well the first thing we need
to do is get human beings to make
decisions about which which of those
videos are in which category and then we
use that data and and basically you know
take that information that's that's
determined and governed by humans and
and extrapolated or apply it to the
entire set of billions of YouTube videos
and we couldn't we we couldn't get to
all the videos on YouTube well without
the humans and we we couldn't use the
humans to get to all the videos of
YouTube so there's no world in which you
have only one or the other of these
things and just as you said a lot of it
comes down to people at YouTube spending
a lot of time trying to figure out what
are the right policies you know what are
the outcomes based on those policies are
they the kinds of things we want to see
and then once we kind of get a get an
agreement or or build some consensus
around around what the policies are well
then we've got to find a way to
implement those policies across all of
YouTube and that's where both the human
beings we call them evaluators or
reviewers come into play to help us with
that and then and then once we get a lot
of training data from them
then we apply the machine learning
techniques to take it even further do
you have a sense that these human beings
have a bias in some kind of direction
sort of I mean that's the interesting
question we do sort of in autonomous
vehicles and computer vision in general
a lot of annotation and we rarely ask
what bias do the annotators have you
know the it even in the sense that
they're better than they're better
anting certain things and others for
example people are much better at
annotating segmentation at segmenting
cars in a scene versus segmenting bushes
or trees you know there's specific
mechanical reasons for that but also
because the cement its semantics gray
area and and just for a lot of reasons
people are just terrible at annotating
trees okay so in the same kind of sense
do you think of in terms of people
reviewing videos or annotating the
content of videos is there some kind of
bias that you're aware of or seek out in
that human input well we take steps to
try to overcome these kinds of biases or
biases that we think would be
problematic so for instance like we
asked people to have a bias towards
scientific consensus that's something
that we we instruct them to do we ask
them to have a bias towards
demonstration of expertise or
credibility or authoritative nests but
there are other biases that we that we
want to make sure to try to remove and
there's many techniques for doing this
one of them is you send the same thing
to be reviewed to many people and so you
know that's one technique another is
that you make sure that the people that
are doing these sorts of tasks are from
different backgrounds and different
areas of the United States
of the world but then even with all of
that it's possible for certain kinds of
what we would call unfair biases to
creep into machine learning systems
primarily as you said because maybe the
training data itself comes in in in a
biased way and so we also have worked
very hard on the improving the machine
learning systems to remove and reduce
unfair biases when it's when it goes
against or or has involved some
protected class for instance thank you
for exploring with me some of the more
challenging things I'm sure there's a
few more that we'll jump back to but let
me jump into the fun part which is maybe
the basics of the quote-unquote YouTube
algorithm what is the YouTube algorithm
look at to make recommendation for what
to watch next was from a machine
learning perspective or when you search
for a particular term how does it know
what to show you next because it seems
to at least for me do an incredible job
both well that's kind of you to say it
didn't used to do a very good job but
it's gotten better over the years even
even I observed that it's improved quite
a bit
those are two different situations like
when you search for something YouTube
uses the best technology we can get from
Google to make sure that that the
YouTube search system finds what
someone's looking for and of course the
very first things that one thinks about
is okay well does the word occur in the
title for instance you know but there
but there are much more sophisticated
things where we're mostly trying to do
some syntactic match or or maybe a
semantic match based on words that we
can add to the document itself for
instance you know maybe is is this video
watched a lot after this query right
that's something that
we can observe and then as a result make
sure that that that document would be
retrieved for that query now when you
talk about what kind of videos would be
recommended to watch next that's
something again we've been working on
for many years and probably the first
the first real attempt to do that
well was to use collaborative filtering
so you can't describe what collaborative
filtering is sure it's just basically
what we do is we observe which videos
get watched close together by the same
person and if you observe that and if
you can imagine creating a graph where
the videos that get watched close
together by the most people are sort of
very close to one another in this graph
and videos that don't frequently get
watch close too close together by the
same person or the same people are far
apart then you end up with this graph
that we call the related graph that
basically represents videos that are
very similar or related in some way and
what's amazing about that is that it
puts all the videos that are in the same
language together for instance and we
didn't even have to think about language
just does it yeah I didn't it puts all
the videos that are about sports
together and it puts most of the music
videos together and it puts all of these
sorts of videos together just because
that's sort of the way the people using
YouTube behave so that already cleans up
a lot of the problem it takes care of
the lowest hanging fruit which happens
to be a huge one of just managing these
millions of videos that's right I
remember a few years ago I was talking
to someone who was trying to propose
that we do a research project concerning
people who who are bilingual and this
person
was making this proposal based on the
idea that YouTube could not possibly be
good at recommending videos well to
people who are bilingual and so she was
telling me about this and I said well
can you give me an example of what
problem do you think we have on YouTube
with the recommendations and so she said
well I'm a researcher in in the US and
and when I'm looking for academic topics
I want to look I want to see them in
English and so she searched for one
found a video and then looked at the
watch next suggestions and they were all
in in English and so she said oh I see
YouTube must think that I speak only
English and so she said now I'm actually
originally from Turkey and sometimes
when I'm cooking let's say I want to
make some baklava I really like to watch
videos that are in Turkish and so she
searched for a video about making the
baklava and then and then selected it it
was in Turkish and the watch next
recommendations were in Turkish and she
just couldn't believe how this was
possible and how is it that you know
that I speak both these two languages
and put all the videos together and it's
just as a route come of this related
graph that's created through
collaborative filtering so for me one of
my huge interest is just human
psychology right and and that's such a
powerful platform on which to utilize
human psychology to discover what people
individual people want to watch next but
it's also be just fascinating to me
you know I've Google search has ability
to look at your own history and I've
done that before
just just what I've searched three years
for many many years and it's fascinating
picture of Who I am actually and I don't
think anyone's ever summarized that I
personally would love that a summary of
who I am as a person on the Internet to
me because I think it reveals I I think
it puts a mirror to me or to others you
know that's actually quite revealing and
interesting you know just maybe in the
number of it's a joke but not really is
the
of cat videos I've watched videos of
people falling you know stuff that's
absurd that kind of stuff it's really
interesting and of course it's really
good for the machine learning aspect to
to show to figure out what to show next
but it's interesting hey have you just
as a tangent played around with the idea
of giving a map to people sort of as
opposed to just using this information
to show us next showing them here are
the clusters you've loved over the years
kind of thing well we do provide the
history of all the videos that you've
watched yes so you can definitely search
through that and look through it and
search through it to see what it is that
you've been watching on YouTube we have
actually in various times experimented
with this sort of cluster idea finding
ways to demonstrate or show people what
topics they've been interested in or
what what clusters they've watched from
it's interesting that you bring this up
because in some sense the way the
recommendation system of YouTube sees a
user is exactly as the history of all
the videos they've watched on YouTube
and so you can think of yourself or any
user on YouTube as kind of like a DNA
strand of all your videos right that
sort of represents you you can also
think of it as maybe a vector in the
space of all the videos on YouTube and
so you know now once you think of it as
a vector in the space of all the videos
on YouTube then you can start to say
okay well you know which videos which
which other vectors are close to me and
to my vector and and that's one of the
ways that we generate some diverse
recommendations is because you're like
okay well you know these these people
seem to be closed with respect to the
videos they've watched on YouTube but
you know here's a topic or a video that
one of them has watched and enjoyed but
the other one hasn't that could be an
opportunity to make a good
recommendation I gotta tell you I mean I
know
for things that are impossible but I
would love to cluster than human beings
like I would love to know who has
similar trajectories as me you probably
would want to hang out alright there's a
social aspect there like actually
finding some of the most fascinating
people I find out in YouTube but have
like no followers and I start following
them and they create incredible content
and you know and on that topic I just
love to ask there's some videos just
blow my mind in terms of quality and
depth and just in every regard are
amazing videos and they have like 57
views okay how do you get videos of
quality to be seen by many eyes so the
measure of quality is it just something
yeah how do you know that something is
good well I mean I think it depends
initially on what sort of video we're
talking about so in the realm of let's
say you mentioned politics and news in
that realm you know quality news or
quality journalism relies on having a
journalism department right like you you
have to have actual journalists and
fact-checkers and people like that and
so in that situation and in others maybe
science or in medicine quality has a lot
to do with the authoritative nough sand
the credibility and the expertise of the
people who make the video now if you're
thinking about the other end of the
spectrum you know what is the highest
quality prank video for what is the
highest quality minecraft video yeah
right that might be the one that people
enjoy watching the most and watch to the
end or it might be the one that when we
ask people the next day after they
watched it were they satisfied with it
and so we in in especially in the realm
of entertainment have been trying to get
at better and better measures of quality
or satisfaction or enrichment
since I came to YouTube and we started
with well you know the first
approximation is the one that gets more
views but but you know we both know that
things can get a lot of views and not
really be that high quality especially
if people are clicking on something and
then immediately realizing that it's not
that great and abandoning it and that's
why we move from views to thinking about
the amount of time people spend watching
it what the premise that like you know
in some sense the time that someone
spends watching a video is related to
the value that they get from that video
it may not be perfectly related but it
has something to say about how much
value they get but even that's not good
enough
right because I myself have spent time
clicking through channels on television
late at night and ended up watching
under siege - for some reason I don't
know and if you were to ask me the next
day are you glad that you watched that
show on TV last night I'd say yeah I
wish I would have gone to bed or read a
book or almost anything else really and
so that's why some people got the idea a
few years ago to try to serve at users
afterwards and so so we get feedback
data from those surveys and then use
that in the machine learning system to
try to not just predict what you're
gonna click on right now what you might
watch for a while but what when we ask
you tomorrow you'll give four or five
stars - so just to summarize what are
the signals from a machine learning
perspective the user can provide he
mentions just clicking on the video
views the time watch maybe the relative
time watched the clicking like and
dislike on the video maybe commenting on
the video and those things all of those
things and then though the one I wasn't
actually quite aware of even though I
might have engaged in it is a survey
afterwards which is a brilliant idea is
there other signals all right I mean
that's already a really rich space of
signals to learn from is
something else well you mentioned
commenting also sharing the video if you
if you think it's worthy to be shared
with someone else you know within
YouTube or outside of YouTube as well
either
let's see you mentioned like dislike
yeah like and dislike how important is
that it's very important right we want
its predictive of satisfaction but it's
not it's not perfectly predictive
subscribe if you subscribe to the
channel of the person who made the video
then that also is a piece of information
and signals satisfaction although over
the years we've learned that people have
a wide range of attitudes about what it
means to subscribe we would ask some
users who didn't subscribe very much why
but they watched a lot from a few
channels we'd say well why didn't you
subscribe and they would say well I I
can't afford to pay for anything and you
know we tried to let them understand
like actually it doesn't cost anything
it's free it just helps us know that you
are very interested in this creator but
then we've asked other people who
subscribed to many things and and don't
really watch any of the videos from
those channels and we say well well why
did you subscribe to this if you weren't
really interested in any more videos
from that channel and they might tell us
why just you know I thought the person
did a great job and I just want to kind
of give him a high five yeah yeah and so
yeah that's where I I said I should
subscribe to channels where I just this
person is amazing I like this person but
then I like this person I really want to
support them that that's how I click
Subscribe right even though I may never
actually want to click on their videos
when they're releasing it I just love
what they're doing and it's maybe
outside of my interest area and so on
which is probably the wrong way to use
the subscribe button but I just want to
say congrats this is a great work well
so you have to deal with all the space
of people that see the subscribe button
it's totally different that's right and
so you know we we can't just close our
eyes and say
sorry you're using it wrong you know and
we're not gonna pay attention to what
you've done we need to embrace all the
ways in which all the different people
in the world use the subscribe button or
the like in the dislike button so in
terms of signals of machine learning
using for the search and for the
recommendation
you've mentioned title so like metadata
like text data that people provide
description and title and maybe keywords
so maybe you can speak to the value of
those things in search and also this
incredible fascinating area of the
content itself so the video content
itself trying to understand what's
happening in the video so YouTube would
release a dataset that you know the in
the machine learning and computer vision
world this is just an exciting space how
much is that currently how much he
playing with that currently how much is
your hope for the future of being able
to analyze the content of the video
itself well we have been working on that
also since I came to YouTube analyzing
the content analyzing the content while
video right
and what I can tell you is that our
ability to do it well is still somewhat
crude we can we can tell if it's a music
video
we can tell if it's a sports video we
can probably tell you that people are
playing soccer we probably can't tell
whether it's Manchester United or my
daughter's soccer team so these things
are kind of difficult and and using them
we can use them in some ways so for
instance we use that kind of information
to understand and inform these clusters
that I talked about and also maybe to
add some words like soccer for instance
to the video if if it doesn't occur in
the title or the description which is
remarkable that often it doesn't I one
of the things that I ask creators to do
is is please help us out with the title
in the description for instance we were
a a few years ago having a live stream
of some competition for World of
Warcraft
on YouTube
and it was a very important competition
but if you typed World of Warcraft in
search you wouldn't find it
well the Warcraft wasn't in the title
World of Warcraft wasn't in the title it
was match four seven eight you know a
team versus B team and World of Warcraft
wasn't the title yes like come on give
me being literal being literal on the
Internet is actually very uncool
which is the problem oh is that right
well I mean in some sense well some of
the greatest videos I mean there's a
humor to just being indirect being witty
and so on and actually being you know
machine learning algorithms want you to
be you know literal right usually want
to say what's in the thing be very very
simple and in in some sense that gets
away from wit and humor so you have to
play with both right so but you're
saying that for now sort of the content
of the title the content of the
description the actual text is is one of
the best ways to uh for the for the
algorithm to find your video and put
them in the right cluster that's right
and and I would go further and say that
if you want people human beings to
select your video in search then it
helps to have let's say World of
Warcraft in the title because why would
a person's you know if they're looking
at a bunch they type World of Warcraft
and they have a bunch of videos all of
whom say World of Warcraft except the
one that you uploaded well even the
person is gonna think well maybe this
isn't some house search made a mistake
this isn't really about World of
Warcraft so it's important not just for
the machine learning systems but also
for the people who might be looking for
this sort of thing they get a clue that
it's what they're looking for by seeing
that same thing prominently in the title
of the video okay let me push back on
that so I think from the algorithmic
perspective yes but if they typed in
World of Warcraft and saw a video that
with the title simply winning and and
and the thumbnail has like a sad orc or
something I don't know right like I
think that's much it's Iraq it gets your
curiosity up
and then if they could trust that the
algorithm was smart enough to figure out
somehow that this is indeed a World of
Warcraft video that would have created
the most beautiful experience I think in
terms of just the wit and the humor and
the curiosity that we human beings
actually have but you're saying I mean
realistically speaking is really hard
for the algorithm to figure out that the
content of that video will be a world of
warcraft and you have to accept that
some people are gonna skip it
yeah right I mean and so you're right
the people who don't skip it and select
it are gonna be delighted yeah but other
people say might say but yeah this is
not what I was looking for and making
stuff discoverable I think is what
you're really working on and hoping so
yeah so from your perspective to put
stuff in the description and remember
the collaborative filtering part of the
system it starts by the same user
watching videos together right so the
way that they're probably going to do
that is by searching for them that's a
fascinating aspect it's like ant
colonies that's how they find stuff is
so I mean you would agree for
collaborative filtering in general is
one curious ant
one curious user essential sort of just
a person who is more willing to click on
random videos and sort of explore these
cluster spaces in your sense how many
people are just like watching the same
thing over and over and over and over
and how many are just like the explorers
I just kind of like click on stuff and
then help help the other ant and the
ants colony discover the cool stuff do
you have a sense of that or no I really
don't think I have a sense me OK
relative sizes of those groups but I but
I would say that you know people come to
YouTube with some certain amount of
intent and as long as they to the extent
to which they they try to satisfy that
intent that certainly helps our systems
right because our systems rely on on
kind of a faithful amount of behavior
the right like and there are people who
try to trick us right there are people
and machines that try to associate
videos together that
really don't belong together but they're
trying to get that Association made
because it's profitable for them and so
we have to always be resilient to that
sort of attempt at gaming the system so
speaking to that there's a lot of people
that in a positive way perhaps I don't
know I I don't like it but I like to
gain want to try to gain the system to
get more attention and everybody
creators in a positive sense want to get
attention right so how do you how do you
work in this space when people create
more and more sort of click Beatty
titles and thumbnails sort of a very
tasking derek has made a video it
basically describes that it seems what
works is to create a high quality video
really good video what people would want
to watch and wants to click on it
but have clicked BT titles and
thumbnails to get him to click on it in
the first place and he's saying I'm
embracing this bactrim just gonna keep
doing it and I hope you forgive me for
doing it and you will enjoy my videos
once you click on them so in what sense
do you see this kind of clickbait style
attempt to manipulate to get people in
the door to manipulate the algorithm or
play with the algorithmic game the
algorithm I think that that you can look
at it as an attempt to game the
algorithm but even if you were to take
the algorithm out of it and just say ok
well all these videos happen to be lined
up which the algorithm didn't make any
decision about which one to put at the
top or the bottom but they're all lined
up there which one are the people going
to choose and and I'll tell you the same
thing that I told Derek is you know I
have a bookshelf and they have two kinds
of books on them science books I have my
math books from when I was a student and
they all look identical except for the
titles on the covers they're all yellow
they're all from Springer and they're
every single one of them the cover is
totally the same yes right yeah on the
other hand I have other more pop science
type books and they all have very
interesting covers right and they have
provocative
titles and things like that I mean I
wouldn't say that they're clickbait II
because they are indeed good books and I
don't think that they cross any line but
but you know the that's just a decision
you have to make right like the people
who who write classical recursion theory
by pure OD Freddie he was fine with the
yellow title and the and nothing more
whereas I think other people who who
wrote a more popular type book
understand that they need to have a
compelling cover and a compelling title
and and you know I don't think there's
anything really wrong with that we do we
do take steps to make sure that there is
a line that you don't cross and if you
go too far maybe your thumbnails
especially racy or or you know it's all
cats with too many exclamation points we
observe that users are kind of you know
sometimes offended by that and so so for
the users who were offended by that we
will then depress or suppress those
videos and which reminds me that there's
also another signal where users can say
I don't know if was recently added but I
really enjoy it just saying I don't I
didn't something like I I don't want to
see this video anymore or something like
like this is a like there's certain
videos just cut me the wrong way like
just just jump out at music I don't
wanna I don't want this and it feels
really good to clean that out to be like
I don't that's not that's not for me I
don't know I think that might have been
recently added by this that's also a
really strong signal yes absolutely
right we don't want to make a
recommendation that people are unhappy
with and that makes me that particular
one makes me feel good as a user in
general and as a machine learning person
because I feel like I'm helping the
algorithm my interaction I need you
don't always feel like I'm helping the
algorithm like I'm not reminded of that
fact
like for example Tesla and Otto Pollan
you know on musk create a feeling for
their customers for people their own
test is that there
helping the algorithm of testify like
they're all like a really proud they're
helping nicely learn I think YouTube
doesn't always remind people that you're
helping the algorithm get smarter and
for me I love that idea like we're all
collaboratively like Wikipedia gives
that sense they were all together
creating a beautiful thing
YouTube is uh doesn't always remind me
of that it's uh
this conversation is Right any of that
but well that's a good tip we should
keep that fact in mind when we design
these features well I I'm not sure I I
really thought about it that way but
that's a very interesting perspective
it's an interesting question of
personalization that I feel like when I
click like on a video I'm just improving
my experience it would be great it would
make me personally people are different
but make me feel great if I was helping
also the YouTube algorithm broadly say
something you know saying like there's a
that I don't know if that's human nature
we you want the products you love and I
certainly love YouTube like you want to
help it get smarter and smarter smarter
because there's some kind of coupling
between our lives together being better
if if YouTube was better than I will my
life will be better and that's that kind
of reasoning I'm not sure what that is
and I'm not sure how many people share
that feeling it could be just a machine
learning feeling but at that point how
much personalization is there in terms
of next video recommendations so is it
kind of all really boiling down to a
clustering like you find in ears
clusters to me and so on and that kind
of thing or how much is person s to me
the individual completely it's very very
personalized so your experience will be
quite a bit different from anybody
else's who's watching that same video at
least when they're logged in and the
reason is is that we found that that
users often want two different kinds of
things when they're watching a video
sometimes they want to keep watching
more on that topic or more in that genre
and other times they just
are done and they're ready to move on to
something else and so the question is
well what is this something else and one
of the first things one can imagine is
well maybe something else is the latest
video from some channel to which you've
subscribed and that's gonna be very
different from for you than it is for me
right and and even if it's not something
that you subscribe to it's something
that you watch a lot and again that'll
be very different on a person-by-person
basis and so even the watch next as well
as the homepage of course is quite
personalized so what we met some of the
signals but what a success look like
what a success look like in terms of the
algorithm creating a great long-term
experience for a user or put another way
if you look at the videos I've watched
this month how do you know the algorithm
succeeded for me I think first of all if
you come back and watch more YouTube
then that's one indication that you've
found some value from it so just the
number of hours is a powerful indicator
well I mean not the hours themselves but
the fact that you return on another day
so that's probably the most simple
indicator people don't come back to
things that they don't find value in
right there's a lot of other things that
they could do but like I said I mean
ideally we would like everybody to feel
that YouTube enriches their lives and
that every video they watched is the
best one they've ever watched since
they've started watching YouTube and so
that's why we survey them and ask them
like is this one to five stars and so
our version of success is every time
someone takes that survey they say it's
five stars and if we ask them is this
the best video you've ever seen on
YouTube they say yes every single time
so it's hard to imagine that we would
actually achieve that maybe
asymptotically we would get there but
but that would be what we think success
is it's funny have recently said some
way
I don't know maybe tweeted but that Ray
Dalio has this video on the economic
machine I forget what it's called but
it's a 30-minute video and I said it's
the the greatest video I've ever watched
on YouTube it's it's like I watched the
whole thing and my mind was blown is a
very crisp clean description of how the
at least the American economic system
works
it's a beautiful video and I was just I
wanted to click on something to say this
is the best thing this is the best thing
ever please let me I can't believe I
discovered it I mean the the views and
the likes reflect its quality but I was
almost upset that I haven't found it
earlier and wanted to find other things
like it I don't think I've ever felt
that this is the best video ever and
that was that and to me the ultimate
utopia the best experiences were every
single video where I don't see any of
the videos I regret in every single
video I watch is one that actually helps
me grow helps me enjoy life be happy and
so on well so that's that's that's a
heck of uh the thought that's one of the
most beautiful and ambitious I think
machine learning tasks so when you look
at a society as opposed to any
individual user
do you think of how YouTube is changing
society when you have these millions of
people watching videos growing learning
changing having debates do you have a
sense of yeah what the big impact on
society is because I think it's huge but
you have a sense of what direction we're
taking this world well I mean I think
you know openness has had an impact on
society already there's a lot of what do
you mean by openness well the fact that
unlike other mediums there's not someone
sitting at YouTube who decides before
you can upload your video whether it's
worth having you uploaded
or worth anybody seeing it really right
and so you know there are some creators
who say like I I wouldn't have this
opportunity to
to reach an audience Tyler Oakley often
said that you know he wouldn't have had
this opportunity to reach this audience
if it weren't for YouTube and and so I
think that's one way in which YouTube
has changed Society I know that there
are people that I work with from outside
the United States especially from places
where literacy is low and they think
that YouTube can help in those places
because you don't need to be able to
read and write in order to learn
something important for your life maybe
you know how to do some job or how to
fix something and so that's another way
in which I think YouTube is possibly
changing society so I've worked at
YouTube for eight almost nine years now
and it's fun because I meet people and
you know you tell them where they where
you work you say you work on YouTube and
they immediately say I love you too Yeah
right which is great makes me feel great
but then of course when I ask them well
what is it that you love about YouTube
not one time ever has anybody said that
the search works outstanding or that the
recommendations are great what they
always say
when I ask them what do you love about
YouTube is they immediately start
talking about some channel or some
creator or some topic or some community
that they found on YouTube and that they
just loved yeah and so that has made me
realize that YouTube is really about the
video and connecting the people with the
videos and then everything else kind of
gets out of the way so beyond the video
it's an interesting because you kind of
mentioned creator what about the
connection with just the individual
creators as opposed to just individual
video so like I gave the example of Ray
Dalio video that the video itself is
incredible but there's some people or
just creators that
I love that they're one of the cool
things about people who call themselves
youtubers or whatever is they have a
journey they usually almost all of them
are hurt they suck horribly in the
beginning and then they kind of grow you
know and then there's that genuineness
in their growth so you know YouTube
clearly wants to help creators connect
with their audience in this kind of way
so how do you think about that process
of helping creators grow helping the
connect with their audience develop not
just individual videos but the entirety
of a creators life on YouTube well I
mean we're trying to help creators find
the biggest audience that they can find
and the reason why that's you you
brought up creator versus video the
reason why creator channel is so
important is because if we have a hope
of of people coming back to YouTube well
they have to have in their minds some
sense of what they're gonna find when
they come back to YouTube if YouTube
were just the next viral video and I
have no concept of what the next viral
video could be one time it's a cat
playing a piano and the next day it's
some children interrupting a reporter
and the next day it's you know some
other thing happening then then it's
hard for me to to when I'm not watching
YouTube say gosh I really you know would
like to see something from someone or
about something right and so that's why
I think this connection between fans and
creators so important for both because
it's it's a way of a sort of fostering a
relationship that can play out into the
future let me talk about kind of a dark
and interesting question in general and
again a topic that you or nobody has an
answer to but social media has a sense
of you know it gives us highs and gives
us lows in the sense that so creators
often speak about having sort of burn
burn out and having psychological ups
and
and challenges mentally in terms of
continuing the creation process there's
a momentum there's a huge excited
audience that makes everybody feel that
makes creators feel great and I think
it's more than just financial
I think it's literally just they love
that sense of community it's part of the
reason I upload to YouTube I don't care
about money never well what I care about
is the community but some people feel
like this momentum and even when there's
times in their life when they don't feel
you know the for some reason don't feel
like creating so how do you think about
burnout this mental exhaustion that some
YouTube creators go through that's
something we have an answer for is that
something how do we even think about
that well the first thing is we want to
make sure that the YouTube systems are
not contributing to this sense right and
so we've done a fair amount of research
to demonstrate that you can absolutely
take a break if you are a creator and
you've been uploading a lot we have just
as many examples of people who took a
break and came back more popular than
they were before as we have examples of
going the other way
yeah can we pause on that for a second
so the feeling that people have I think
is if I take a break everybody well the
party will leave right so if you can
just linger on that so in your sense
that taking a break is okay yes taking a
break is absolutely okay and the reason
I say that is because we have we can
observe many examples of being of
creators coming back very strong and
even stronger after they have taken some
sort of break and so I just want to
dispel the myth that this somehow
necessarily means that your channel is
gonna go down or lose views that is not
the case we know for sure that this is
not a necessary outcome and so we we
want to encourage people to make sure
that they take care of themselves that
is job one right you you have to look
after yourself and your mental health
and you know I think that
it probably in some of these cases
contributes to better videos once they
come back right because a lot of people
I mean I know myself if I'm burn out on
something that I'm probably not doing my
best work even though I can keep working
until I pass out and so I think that the
the taking a break may even improve the
creative ideas that someone has okay I
think it's a really important thing to
sort of to dispel I think it applies to
all of social media like literally I've
taken a break for a day every once in a
while sorry sorry that sounds like a
short time but even like sorry email
just taking a break from email or only
checking email once a day especially
when you're going through something
psychologically in your personal life or
so on or really not sleeping much
because it work deadlines it can refresh
you in a way that's that's profound and
so the same applies there when you came
back right it's there and it looks
different actually when you come back
you sort of brighter I'd some coffee
everything the world looks better so
it's important to take a break when you
need it so you've mentioned kind of the
the YouTube algorithm isn't you know e
equals MC squared is that's a single
equation it's it's potentially sort of
more than a million lines of code sort
of is it more akin to what autonomous
successful autonomous vehicles today are
which is they're just basically patches
on top of patches of heuristics and
human experts really tuning the
algorithm and have some machine learning
modules or is it becoming more and more
a giant machine learning system with
humans just doing a little bit of
tweaking here and there what's your
sense first of all do you even have a
sense of what is the YouTube algorithm
at this point and whichever however much
you do have a sense what does it look
like well we don't usually think about
it as the algorithm because it's a bunch
of systems that work on different
services the other
that I think people don't understand is
that what you might refer to as the
YouTube algorithm from outside of
YouTube is actually a you know a bunch
of code and machine learning systems and
heuristics but that's married with the
behavior of all the people who come to
YouTube every day so the people part of
the code Accession exactly right like if
there were no people who came to youtube
tomorrow then there the algorithm
wouldn't work anymore right so that's a
critical part of the algorithm and so
when people talk about well the
algorithm does this the algorithm does
that it's sometimes hard to understand
well you know it could be the the
viewers are doing that and the algorithm
is mostly just keeping track of what the
viewers do and then reacting to those
things in in sort of more fine-grained
situations and I and I think that this
is the way that the recommendation
system and the search system and and
probably many machine learning systems
evolve is you know you start trying to
solve a problem and the first way to
solve a problem is often with a simple
heuristic right and and you know you
want to say what are the videos we're
gonna recommend well how about the most
popular ones weighted that's where you
start and and over time you collect some
data and you refine your situations so
that you're making less heuristics and
you're you're building a system that can
actually learn what to do in different
situations based on some observations of
those situations in the past and and you
keep chipping away at these heuristics
over time and so I think that just like
with diversity you know I think the
first diversity measure we took was okay
not more than three videos in a row from
the same Channel right it's a pretty
simple heuristic to encourage diversity
it worked right you needs to see four or
five six videos in a row from the same
Channel and over time we try to chip
away at that it and make it more
fine-grain and basically have it
remove the heuristics in favor of
something that can react to
individuals and individual situations so
how do you you mentioned you know we we
know that something worked how do you
get a sense when decisions of a kind of
a be testing that this idea was a good
one this was not so good what's how do
you measure that
and across which time scale across how
many users that kind of that kind of
thing well you mentioned that a B
experiments and so just about every
single change we make to YouTube we do
it only after we've run a a B experiment
and so in those experiments which run
from one week to months we measure
hundreds literally hundreds of different
variables and and measure changes with
confidence intervals in all of them
because we really are trying to get a
sense for ultimately does this improve
the experience for viewers that's the
question we're trying to answer and an
experiment is one way because we can see
certain things go up and down so for
instance if we noticed in the experiment
people are dismissing videos less
frequently or they're saying that
they're more satisfied they're giving
more videos five stars after they watch
them then those would be indications of
that the experiment is successful that
it's improving the situation for viewers
but we can also look at other things
like we might do user studies where we
invite some people in and ask them like
what do you think about this what do you
think about that how do you feel about
this and other various kinds of user
research but ultimately before we launch
something we're gonna want to run an
experiment so we get a sense for what
the impact is going to be not just to
the viewers but also to the different
channels and all of them an absurd
question nobody know what actually is
interesting maybe there's an answer but
if I want to make a viral video
how do I do it I don't know how you make
a viral video I
I know that we have in the past tried to
figure out if we could detect when a
video video was going to go viral you
know and those were you take the first
and second derivatives of the view count
and maybe use that to do some prediction
but but I can't say we ever got very
good at that
oftentimes we look at where the traffic
was coming from you know if it's if it's
a lot of the viewership is coming from
something like Twitter then then maybe
it has a higher chance of becoming viral
than maybe if then if it were coming
from search or something but that was
just trying to detect a video that might
be viral how to make one like I have no
idea so yeah you get your kids to
interrupt you while you're on the news
on the news absolutely as but after the
fact on a one individual video so the
head of time predicting is a really hard
task but after the video went viral in
analysis can you sometimes understand
why I went viral from the perspective of
YouTube broadly first I was even
interesting for YouTube that a
particular videos viral or is does that
not matter for the individual for the
experience of people well I think people
expect that if a video video is going
viral and it's something they would be
interested in then I wouldn't I think
they would expect YouTube to recommend
it to them right um so someone's going
viral it's good to just let the wave
ride the wave of its violence well I
mean we want to meet people's
expectations in that way of course so
like like I mentioned I hung out with
Derek Muller a while ago a couple of
months back he's actually the person who
suggested I talk to you on this podcast
all right well thank you Derek at that
time he just recently posted an awesome
science video titled why are ninety-six
million black balls on this reservoir
and in a matter of I don't know how long
but like a few days he got thirty
million views and it's still growing is
this something you can analyze and
understand why it happened this video
and you won't particularly
like it I mean we can surely see where
it was recommended where it was found
who watched it and those sorts of things
so it's actually sorry to interrupt it
is the video which helped me discover
who Derek is I didn't know who he is
before so I remember you know usually I
just have all of these technical boring
MIT Stanford talks in my recommendation
because that's how I watch and then all
sudden there's this black balls in
reservoir video with like an excited
nerd in the would like just and why is
this being recommended to me so I close
down and watch the whole thing it was
awesome but and a lot of people had that
experience like why was I recommend this
but they all of course watched it and
enjoyed it which is what's your sense of
this just wave of recommendation and
that comes with this viral video that
ultimately people get enjoy after they
click on it well I think it's the system
you know basically doing what anybody
who's recommending something would do
which is you show it to some people and
if they like it you say okay well can I
find some more people who are a little
bit like them okay I'm gonna try it with
them oh they like it too let me expand
the circle some more find some more
people
oh it turns out they like it too so can
you just keep going until you get some
feedback that says no now you've gone
too far these people don't like it
anymore
and so I think that's basically what
happened now
you asked me about how to make a video
go viral or make a viral video I don't
think that if you or I decided to make a
video about 96 million balls that it
would also go viral it's possible that
Derek made like um the canonical video
about those black balls yeah lake and so
he did actually right and and so I don't
know whether or not just following along
is the secret yeah but it's fascinating
I mean just like you said the algorithm
sort of expanding that circle and then
figuring out that more and more people
did enjoy and that sort of phase shift
of just a huge number of people enjoying
in the algorithm quickly automatically I
assume figuring that out that's a I
don't know
the dynamics in psychology that is a
beautiful thing and so what do you think
about the idea of of clipping like and
too many people annoyed me into doing it
which is they were requesting it I said
very beneficial to add clips in like the
the coolest points and actually have
explicit videos like I'm reapplying a
video like a short clip which is what
the the podcasts are doing yeah do you
see as opposed to like I also add time
stamps for the topics no people want the
clip do you see YouTube somehow helping
creators with that process or helping
connect clips to the original videos
what is that just in a long list of
amazing things to work towards yeah I
mean it's not something that I think
we've we've done yet but I can tell you
that I think clipping is great and I
think it's actually great for you as a
creator and here's the reason if you
think about I mean let's let's say the
NBA is uploading videos of of its games
well people might search for warriors
vs. rockets or they might search for
Steph Curry and so a highlight from the
game in which Steph Curry makes an
amazing shot is an opportunity for
someone to find a portion of that video
and so I think that you never know how
people are gonna search for something
that you've created and so you wanna I
would say you want to make clips and and
add titles and things like that so that
they can find it as easily as possible
do you have a dream of a future perhaps
a distant future when the YouTube
algorithm figures that out sort of
automatically detects the parts of the
video that are really interesting
exciting potentially exciting for people
and sort of clip them out in this
incredibly rich space if you talk about
if you thought even just this
conversation we probably covered 30 40
little topics and there's a huge space
of users that would find you know 30
percent of those topics interesting and
that's
is very different it's something that's
beyond my ability to clip out right but
the algorithm might be able to figure
all that out sort of expand into clips
do you ever you think about this kind of
thing do you have a hope a dream that
one day the album will be able to do
that kind of deep content analysis well
we've actually had projects that attempt
to achieve this but it really does
depend on understanding the video well
and our understanding of the video right
now is quite crude and so I think it
would be especially hard to do it with a
conversation like this one might be able
to do it with let's say a soccer match
more easily right you could probably
find out where the goals were scored and
then of course you you need to figure
out who it was that scored the goal and
and that might require human to do some
annotation but I think that trying to
identify coherent topics in a transcript
like like the one of our conversation is
is not something that we're gonna be
very good at right away and I was
speaking more to the general problem
actually of being able to do both a
soccer match and our conversation
without explicit sort of almost my hope
was that there exists an algorithm
that's able to find exciting things in
video so Google now on Google search
will help you find the segment of the
video that you're interested in so if
you search for something like how to
change the filter in my dishwasher then
if there's a long video about your
dishwasher and this is the part where
the person shows you how to change the
filter then then it will highlight that
area and provide a link directly to it
and you know if from your recollection
do you know if the thumbnail reflects
like what's the difference between
showing the full video and the shorter
clip do you know what how its presented
in search results don't remember how its
presented and the other thing I would
say is that right now it's based on
creator annotations got it so it's not
the thing I'm talking about
but there but but folks are working on
the more automatic version it's
interesting people might not imagine
this but a lot of our systems start by
using almost entirely the audience
behavior and then as they get better the
refinement comes from using the content
and I wish and I know there's privacy
concerns but I wish YouTube explored the
space which is sort of putting a camera
on the user's if they allowed it right
to study there like I did a lot of
emotion recognition work and so on to
study actual sort of rich or signal one
of the cool things when you upload 360
like VR video to YouTube and I've done
this a few times so I've uploaded myself
it's a horrible idea
some people enjoyed it but whatever the
video of me giving a lecture in 360 over
360 camera it's cool because YouTube
allows you to then watch where did
people look at there's a heat map of
where you know avoid the center of the
VR experience was and it's interesting
because that reveals to you like what
people looked at and it's it's very not
always what you were though it's not in
the case of the lecture is pretty boring
it is what we're expecting but we did a
few funny videos where there's a bunch
of people doing things and they
everybody tracks those people you know
in the beginning they all look at the
main person and they start spreading
around and looking into other people
it's fascinating so that kind of that's
a really strong signal of what people
found exciting in the video I don't know
how you get that from people just
watching except they tuned out at this
point
like it's hard to measure this moment
was super exciting for people I don't
know how you get that signal maybe
comment is there a way to get that
signal where this was like this is when
their eyes opened up they're like like
for me with the Ray Dalio video right
like first I was like okay this is
another one of these like dumb it down
for you videos and then you like start
watching it's like okay there's really
crisp clean deep explanation of how the
economy works that's where I like set up
and started watch right at that moment
is there a way to detect that
the only way I can think of is by asking
people to just label it yeah you
mentioned that we're quite far away in
terms of doing video analysis deep video
analysis ago of course Google YouTube
you know we're quite far away from
solving autonomous driving problem - yes
I don't know I think we're closer to
that what the you know you never know
and the Wright brothers thought they're
never they're not gonna five fifty years
three years before they flew so what are
the biggest challenges would you say is
it the broad challenge of understanding
video understanding natural language
understanding the the challenge before
the entire machine learning community or
just being able to understand data is
there something specific to video that's
even more challenging than an
understanding natural language
understanding what's your sense of what
the biggest video is just so much
information and so precision becomes a
real problem it's like a you know you're
trying to classify something and you've
got a million classes and you the
distinctions among them at least from a
from a machine learning perspective are
often pretty small right like you know
you need to see this person's number in
order to know which player it is and and
there's a lot of players or you need to
see you know the logo on their chest in
order to know like which which team they
play for and so and that's just figuring
out who's who right and then you go
further and saying okay well you know
was that a goal was it not a goal like
is that an interesting moment as you
said or is that not an interesting
moment these things can be pretty hard
so okay so yawn laocoön I'm not sure if
you're familiar sort of with his current
thinking and work so he believes that
self what is referring to self
supervised learning will be the solution
sort of to achieving this kind of
greater level of intelligence in fact
the thing he's focusing on
is watching video and predicting the
next frame so predicting the future of
video right so for now we're very far
from that but his thought is because
it's unsupervised uh-huh or is it here
first to a self supervise you know if
you watch enough video essentially if
you watch YouTube you'll be able to
learn about the nature of reality the
physics the common sense reasoning
required by just teaching a system to
predict the next frame so he's confident
this is the way to go so see you from
the perspective of just working with
this video how do you think an algorithm
that just watches all of YouTube stays
up all day and night watching YouTube
will be able to understand enough of the
physics of the world about the way this
world works failed to do common-sense
reasoning and so on well I mean we have
systems that already watch all the
videos on YouTube right but they're just
looking for very specific things right
they're supervised learning systems that
are trying to identify something or
classify something and I don't know if I
don't know if predicting the next frame
is really gonna get there because I
don't I'm not an expert on compression
algorithms but I understand that that's
kind of what compression video
compression algorithms do is they
basically try to predict the next frame
and and and then fix up the places where
they got it wrong and that leads to
higher compression and if you actually
put all the bits for the next frame
there so so I I don't know if I believe
that just being able to predict the next
frame is gonna be enough because because
there's so many frames and even a tiny
bit of error on a per frame basis can
lead wildly different videos so the
thing is the idea of compression is one
way to do compression is to describe
through text with containing the video
that's the ultimate high level of
compression so the idea is tradition
when you think of video image
compression you're trying to maintain
the same visual quality while reducing
the size but if you think of deep
learning from a bigger perspective
what compression is is you're trying to
summarize the video and the idea there
is if you have a big enough neural
network this by watching the next bit
trying to predict the next frame you'll
be able to form a compression of
actually understanding what's going on
in the scene if there's two people
talking you can just reduce that entire
video and into the fact that two people
are talking and maybe the content of
what they're saying and so on that
that's kind of the the open-ended dream
so I just wanted to sort of express it
because it's interesting compelling
notion but it is nevertheless true that
video our world is a lot more
complicated than we getting credit for I
mean in terms of search and discovery we
have been working on trying to summarize
videos in text or or with some kind of
labels for eight years at least and
we're kind of so so so and so if you
would say it's the problem is a hundred
percent solved and eight years ago was
zero percent solved how where are we on
that timeline would you say yeah to
summarize a video well maybe less than a
quarter of the way so on that topic
what does YouTube look like ten twenty
thirty years from now I mean I think
that YouTube is evolving to take the
place of TV you know I grew up as a kid
in the 70s and I watched a tremendous
amount of television and I feel sorry
for my poor mom because people told her
at the time that it was going to rot my
brain and that she should kill her
television but anyway I mean I think
that YouTube is at least for my family a
better version of television right it's
one that is on demand it's more tailored
to the things that my kids want to watch
and also they can find things that they
would never have found on television and
so I think that at least from just
observing my own family
that's where we're headed is that people
watch YouTube kind of in the same way
that I watch television when I was
younger so from a search and discovery
perspective what do you what are you
excited about and then the 5 10 20 30
years like what kind of things it's
already really good I think it's
achieved a lot of of course we don't
know what's possible so it's a it's the
the task of search of typing in the text
or discovering new videos by the next
recommendation I personally I'm really
happy with the experience that
continuously I rarely watch a video
that's not awesome from my own
perspective but what's what's else is
possible what are you excited about well
I think introducing people to more of
what's available on YouTube is not only
very important to YouTube in to creators
but I think it will help enrich people's
lives because there's a lot that I'm
still finding out is available on
YouTube that I didn't even know I've
been working YouTube eight years and it
wasn't until last year that I learned
that that I could watch USC football
games from the 1970s
no like I didn't even know that was
possible last year and I've been working
there quite some time so you know what
was broken about about that but it took
me seven years to learn that this stuff
was already on YouTube even when I got
here so I think there's a big
opportunity there and then as I said
before you know we want to make sure
that YouTube finds a way to ensure that
it's acting responsibly with respect to
society and enriching people's lives so
we want to take all of the great things
that it does and make sure that we are
eliminating the negative consequences
that might happen and then lastly if we
could get to a point where all the
videos people watch are the best ones
they've ever watched that would be
outstanding to do you see in many senses
becoming a window into the world for
people and it's especially with live
video you get to watch events I mean
it's really it's the way you experience
a lot of the world that's out there is
better than TV in many many ways so do
you see becoming more than just video do
you see creators creating visual
experiences and virtual worlds so if I'm
talking crazy now but sort of virtual
reality and entering that space there's
that at least for now totally outside of
what YouTube is thinking about I mean I
think Google is thinking about virtual
reality
I don't think about virtual reality too
much um I know that we would want to
make sure that YouTube is there when
virtual reality becomes something or if
virtual reality becomes something that a
lot of people are interested in but I
haven't seen it really take off yet take
off well the the future is wide open
christos I've been really looking
forward to this conversation has been a
huge honor thank you for answering some
of the more difficult questions I've
asked I'm really excited about what
YouTube has in store for us it's one of
the greatest products of ever use and
continues so thank you so much for
talking it it's my pleasure thanks for
asking me
thanks for listening to this
conversation and thank you to our
presenting sponsor cash app downloaded
use code Lex podcast you'll get ten
dollars and ten dollars will go to first
a stem education nonprofit that inspires
hundreds of thousands of young minds to
become future leaders and innovators if
you enjoy this podcast subscribe on
YouTube
give it five stars an apple podcast
follow on Spotify supported on patreon
or simply connect with me on Twitter now
let me leave you with some words of
wisdom from Marcel Proust the real
voyage of discovery consists not in
seeking new landscapes but in having new
eyes thank you for listening I hope to
see you next time
you